the argument is that marriage is an
oppressive tool which I say
yes it is when motherhood became a
biological choice for women fatherhood
became a social choice for men it became
socially acceptable for men to walk away
from children in a way that it hadn't
been before those High status men are
able to really really set the terms if a
woman doesn't say have sex on a first
date it's easy enough to find another
woman who else who ends up with a
slightly artificial level of competition
between women who you know there are
actually enough men to go around but
there aren't enough men that they
actually want to be with to go around
and so they're competing for a minority
of men who basically have I mean it's
kind of Open Season they can demand that
their own preferences be met
[Music]
Louise Perry it's very nice to meet you
and you what a pleasure to be here yeah
this should be good thank you very much
for agreeing to come on I'm excited for
this conversation before we get started
can you give a brief background about
who you are and what it is you do I am a
British journalist based in London and a
campaigner and I the director of a think
tank called the other half which may
begin to talk about which is um we
promote what we call Common Sense
feminism wow yeah
and uh and I'm an author of the new book
called case against sexual Revolution
case against the sexual Revolution okay
this should be good how much negativity
do you get online less than you'd think
good I thought yeah I thought that I'd
get loads but actually I would say 90
positive well you have a very nice soft
voice too maybe that's what it is
who mad at you oh that's nice I think
you might be the English accent as well
yeah but sneaky that's it makes people
sound smarter too it's kind of like a
cheat code in life oh yeah yeah
okay this should be good so what's your
book what's your book about and what is
common sense feminism let's start with
what is common sense feminism actually I
mean partly it's a nice phrase that sort
of confuses people
deserves calling a book something like
the case against a social Evolution it's
a bit it's a bit confounding isn't it
what we're trying to do with the other
half the reason we called it the other
half is because
it's not only about talking about women
you know the other half of the human
race it's also about talking about the
other half of life because
my view that I put forward in the book
is that what the feminist project has
been at least in the second half of the
20th century until now has been about
encouraging women to be more like men in
every possible way so to imitate male
sexuality to gain access to the male
sphere to imitate the male life cycle in
terms of things like prioritizing
professional success over anything else
all this sort of stuff and I think it is
very clear and is becoming clearer over
time that this isn't making women happy
and that actually most women do not see
that as their aspiration in life most
women want to either prioritize family
life or to or to balance it against
career most women want to spend more
time with their children not less most
women want to Aspire to stable and
meaningful monogamous relationships
rather than have sex like a man have sex
and [ __ ] described it and this is
extremely obvious from polling you ask
Bush women and indeed American women all
of these questions and it's a fair
there's a fairly resounding majority but
that isn't what you hear represented in
Westminster or indeed in Washington
because there's a really big gap between
what most feminist lobbying
organizations
rather because the organizations of all
kinds and and also in the media
tend to represent as what women want and
what women do actually want so the the
project that we've set ourselves is to
try and represent
majority female opinion
in the corridors of power
wow okay are you making any progress
It's very early days but yes I would say
yes
good
good
um do you know the background of why
their sexual Revolution kind of pushed
women towards acting more like men
it's an interesting question I think
it's probably partly got to do with the
women who
who forms the second wave
um I think that the
the feminist culture of the 1970s
um which was really focused in places
like Greenwich Village in New York and a
handful of other Urban centers
and the women who who wrote the most
important text of the second wave and
went on to found organizations like now
tended to to be super super well
educated
super intelligent super disagreeable
particularly
disinclined towards things like family
life you know the whole the whole from
their from their point of view they were
really spurred on by a desire to reject
the traditional feminine role and often
did so in quite spectacular ways you
know on a personal level some of the
biographies the second waivers are
really really unusual really interesting
and so they obviously had preferences
that are different from average female
preferences which isn't to say that
everything that they campaigned for was
kind of misaligned with what is good for
most women you know things like setting
up domestic violence shelters or certain
crisis centers my first job working out
of University was um was working in a
red crisis center those are the kind of
Institutions formed from the second wave
which are you know like really good I
don't think anyone I think very few even
anti-feminists would argue against the
establishment of those kind of
institutions
but I think they were also just
generally geared towards aspiring to a
more masculine way of living
just on the basis of self-selection and
personality than our most women that
would be my guess as to why the
priorities kind of tended in that
direction
that's interesting that totally makes
sense too a bunch of disagreeable
extremely smart women pushed Society in
a direction that doesn't represent the
average woman yeah yeah wow although I'd
also say that I think that the feminist
thinking has been important and has and
has um
shaped our recent history and all sorts
of important ways but it it all comes
secondary to material changes
all of it you know the I think it was
Phyllis schlappley who first said that
the washing machine did more to liberate
women than this campaigning
I think this is just so this is
evidently true right and there are so
many ways in which our lives have
dramatically changed within the last
hundred years not just the washing
machine but the pill which is really
forms that yeah the center of my my book
the fact that we now are orientated much
toward much more towards our knowledge
and service-based economy
which de-emphasizes manual manual work
and physical strength which of course
men have morals
um I think all of these things have
have pushed women out of the domestic
sphere and into a more more masculine
roles
um you know it is good for GDP to put it
bluntly to to have women participating
in the workforce and when you have
things like
washing machines and Central Heating and
microwaves and all these things which
mean that the work of running a
household just takes less time it
becomes more possible to for women to do
things like that and when you can also
delay childbearing through the pill and
other contraception women being more
like men becomes possible and becomes
actually economically productive the
problem is that there are all sorts of
costs down the line from that and
actually including economic costs down
the line from that which mean that we're
dealing with some quite painful
trade-offs this episode is sponsored by
nordvpn if you follow the show for a
while then you've probably heard me
complain about how bad Canadian Netflix
is it was bad as a teenager it was it
was annoying to go to America and see
how good Netflix was if you Americans
don't know is bad I mean Netflix has
been bad recently in America too I
suppose but at least it has variety here
I used nordvpn to watch the best shows
on Netflix and online anywhere in the
world from Canada now that I live in
Miami I don't use nordvpn to watch good
Netflix shows but no matter where I go I
like to safeguard my online activity nor
vpn's state-of-the-art encryption
protects you from third parties who want
to watch what you're doing online it
also protects you from hackers malware
and malicious people who might want to
track your online activity
with their incredibly fast coverage some
vpns are so slow nordvpn is a simple way
to guarantee your privacy and keep you
safe online
it's super easy to start using and it
protects you from anyone knowing what
websites you've been visiting and I
think given the political atmosphere
right now it's worth doing just in case
the government gets weird who knows grab
your exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com
tmpp to get a huge discount off your
nordvpn plan plus four months for free
it's completely risk-free with nord's
30-day money-back guarantee so you can
go there see how fast it is forget
you're using a VPN
be protected sign up for nordvpn and
enjoy this episode okay wow well that I
want to cover a bunch from what you just
talked about uh let's start with
economic trade-offs so what are the
economic trade-offs for having I suppose
women in the workplace and less around
children because someone has to look
after the children would be the first
thing so you have this slightly strange
artifacts of the way that we
um measure GDP
where if you have um if a if a mother
goes to work and hires a nanny to do her
role what was her role while she's at
work
um that appears to be economic growth
because you now have in that unit do you
have mother father Nanny all employed as
opposed to just having father employed
it's it's a misleading way of
calculating that though because the you
know the workers the domestic work that
was previously unpaid is still being
done is exactly the same work it's just
been done by someone else and for a wage
um and of course is is
there's all sorts of sort of friction in
that system that wouldn't be there
otherwise because you've got three
rotating parts that need to lock
together unlike in the single owner
household where you just have the one
and then you have someone you have
specialization between mother and father
and you have mother specializing in
domestic work
um instead when you introduce the paid
component everything becomes much more
complex much more liable for collapse so
interestingly it was um Elizabeth Warren
of all people who wrote a book some
decades ago ago called the two income
trap
yeah when you when when both parents are
in in paid employment the household
becomes dependent on both of them being
in paid employment and there's much less
reason for slack whereas what you would
have had previously is is women kind of
dipping in and out of the workforce
particularly working-class women dipping
in and out of the workforce when say
children are a bit older or when
father's earnings have suffered and they
need a bit of extra money and female
labor participation becomes a sort of a
variable that can change over time
depending on economic circumstances
whereas if the family all families are
dependent on two full-time incomes
there's no room for slack there's no
there's no source of other income if if
Hard Times come along and what's more
you will end up competing with so
the lump of Labor fallacy obviously you
know it's not quite true that
um you end up with wages halved by women
entering the workforce because women
entering the workforce does grow the
economy in all sorts of ways but there
are certain products like housing for
instance if you have a fixed supply of
housing in say a good school district
and everyone is competing for to buy
that to buy that housing and everyone is
competing with two incomes rather than
one
you you do end up in a situation which I
think we we're in now where in order to
have a good standard of living you have
to have two incomes unless you have one
extraordinarily High
hi Anna so is that is that a result of
women going back to work or going to
work in the first place is that actually
a direct result of that or did the
housing in the increase in housing
prices come first there are other things
contributing to housing housing prices
um including
I mean the the the thing that is most of
them spoken about in the political
discourse on this is lack of building
which clearly is a factor it's a factor
as well in someone like the UK that you
have this extreme concentration of
high-ending jobs in London
and another in other part in other parts
of the world you have this concentration
of home jobs in in the major cities so
you will expect you know house prices in
San Francisco to Rocket because Silicon
Valley is based nearby
um there are other factors but I think
it is absolutely the case that joint
mortgages the fact that you now have
have two incomes competing for the same
for the same product for the housing
that everyone wants has made it more
difficult for people to live on single
incomes and look there are advantages of
women being in the world I mean I say
this look at me I'm working there are
advantages of women being in the
workforce in all sorts of ways and women
having you know we mentioned domestic
violence briefly that if women have
separate sources of
of income and want to escape an abusive
marriage that's clearly advantageous the
fact that women I mean women on average
are as intelligent as men have all sorts
of skills that are actually really well
suited to Modern economy the fact that
women are more agreeable than men is
actually great in a service economy for
instance
um and increasing I'd say that office
culture and all sorts of the corporate
culture is increasingly feminine and and
actually women can really really
flourish
in that kind of environment so
I I think that the the the idea that we
can just
sweep women out of public life and go
back to the 1950s which is of course an
unusual decade
um and I think that's going to happen
even if we wanted it to but but these
trade-offs exist as with as with any
complex historical change
interesting okay
um you you spoke about the birth control
pill I'm very interested in that I I
know when I was young I was put on the
birth control when I was 14. I think for
my skin you know because you get and
yeah I I didn't stop taking it until I
was 23 when I started reading about
what the birth control does to your
brain and the side effects it can cause
and generally does cause that's what I
figured out since right like depression
things like that uh can you get into
what you think the birth control's done
to society it's interesting when you
talk about that I mean I don't really
write in the book about the past the
personal side effects of control pill
but so many women experience it and just
and just anecdotally I know so many
women who've said they came off the
pedal and their personality is
completely changed yeah and they
realized how because as you say if you
go on as a teenager for acne and then
you're still on it for decades you don't
even know you don't even know also if
you're having a moody teenage phase then
and the moodiness Never Ends then you
don't identify the issues as the pill
it's extremely problematic yeah
especially if you've been taking it for
so long you don't even notice it's like
a vitamin yeah and it shouldn't surprise
us really because we're meddling with
very very important Airlines
um which have all sorts of furniture
effects that we should we don't really
understand I mean we don't
as a as a species we don't really
understand our reproduction system at
all yeah
um and all of the efforts to do things
like growing babies outside of the womb
or sex change or you know any of these
sort of ambitious scientific projects
they're going nowhere like let's be real
yeah it's so much more complex than
anyone can can actually grasp I think
we're a long way away from being able to
do that kind of radical transformation
even if we'd want to I think the idea of
growing I personally find it incredibly
just open the idea of growing babies
outside of the human body oh and you
have it's so narcissistic too it's like
oh we're smart enough to figure this out
that's that's just a narcissistic way of
thinking I think imagine imagine a
newborn who'd never heard his or her
mother's heartbeat I just find that oh
astonishing yeah you're with your like
English accent too it's the like worse
like making descriptions worse yeah so
sad
yeah
um so the pill yeah I mean so in terms
of the social consequences of it I don't
think that we should be surprised that
for the first time in the history of the
world reliably separating sex and
reproduction has had some pretty massive
effects and that those effects have been
uh both positive and negative and and
vast right and the thing that you notice
happening across if you if you know you
look at the the social effects in in the
decade or two immediately following the
introduction of the pill remembering
that it came in two waves so initially
the Pearl was made available to married
women only and then it was made
available to unmarried women as well ah
and then not long afterwards you have I
mean the the timeline in Britain and
America and other
um Western Nations is all about the same
not long afterwards you then get the
decriminalization of abortion and then
not long afterwards you see the the
shotgun marriage
and as an institution like you see you
see marriage rates of all kind falling
off a cliff but you also see the shotgun
marriage which had existed to deal with
unwanted childbearing
disappears as a social tool and the the
really perverse outcome of the pill
which is a beautiful example of the fact
that human beings are very very
complicated in our society they're very
complicated you can't predict how
technology shocks are going to affect
them you see
um rates of single motherhood rise who
would have thought that would happen
right you introduced a technology which
allows women to regulate their fertility
and it leads to a rise in single
motherhood but I think the reason for
that is because the pill isn't 100
effective you know it's all the
contraception is and actually the early
pill in particular you've got quite a
high rate of quite a high failure rate
but you end up with the absolute amount
of premarital sex goes up and therefore
some portion of that is going to result
in an unwanted pregnancy and and some
women for whatever reason don't want to
have an abortion and so you'll end up
with unexpected babies and when the
social institutions that used to exist
to regulate fertility like marriage
have all Fallen away as a result of the
pills introduction that's I mean the the
phrase I use in a book which isn't
original to me I can't remember who
first said it but when motherhood became
a biological choice for women fatherhood
became a social choice for men and it
became socially it became socially
acceptable for men to walk away from
children
um in a way that it hadn't been before
not to say that there hadn't always been
cases of Scoundrels you know
impregnating women and then and then
leaving but it is now the deadbeat dad
is now completely socially acceptable in
a way that he wasn't before and is
really in a way that one of the one of
the winners of the sexual Revolution
because there's now no there's no I mean
the the rates of non-payment of Child
Support are astonishingly high and it
shouldn't surprise us that single
mothers are some of the
um it's the group that the group of
people most likely to be in poverty
while married mothers are least likely
to be which is why I have a chapter at
the end of my book where I make a
feminist case for marriage and say that
actually marriage is completely in the
interests of of mothers and children
that doesn't surprise me at all but
that's that but that has probably been
the most controversial chapter from
feminist readers really yeah oh well
yeah I suppose if you don't think about
it then it would be it's difficult to
wrap your head around I suppose
the the argument is that marriage is an
oppressive tool
um which I say
yes it is or maybe repressive would be a
better way of phrasing it and that the
whole point of it as an institution is
that you make a promise and you're
obliged to keep a promise and that means
that your freedom is limited there are
things that you can't do anymore once
you've entered into that kind of
institution but that applies just as
much to men as it does to women
the purpose of the institution is that
it is controlling but the principle
being once you've established this unit
legally bound together socially bound
together spiritually bound together if
you if you understand in a religious
sense then that is the basis from which
you can form family so it's a kind of it
is yes it's a means of of control and
repression but it's one that permits
your life to begin as a family and also
means you know in extremists that the
nature of sexual asymmetry which despite
all of recent efforts by the trans
movement and so on isn't going away
right men and women are profoundly
different on a cellular level I always I
find it really interesting that the
campaign to deny the existence of
biological differences between men and
women has arisen at exactly the same
time and become perversely successful at
exactly the same time that actually
we're understanding more and more about
how profoundly we do differ oh let's get
into that okay
how do women as men differ is that on a
cellular level yeah so I so in the
obvious ways women are the ones who get
pregnant men are not we are smaller and
weaker than men particularly on in terms
of upper body strength so the the force
that little women can apply
through a punch is about half as much
as a man
um which is a lot right and this is why
you see in um in Elite Athletics the
difference between men and female
athletes
is huge I do wonder whether the the
people the the progressors who are most
in denial
about the differences between men and
women physically I I cannot help us
suspect that they don't do a lot of
sports because I think that if you
participate particularly in strength
based Sports
or like martial arts or anything like
that you were going to it's going to
become immediately apparent men and
women of profoundly different in this
Dimension they're just hanging out with
all the like spindly artist types yeah
very indoorsy yeah
um
so there's those which ought to be
obvious to everyone but there are also
all sorts of really interesting ways
like women's immune systems are very
different from mammals as we saw with
with coverage men were more likely to
die from covert and it was partly to do
with things like men
um certain lifestyle factors that might
make a difference but it was also just
to do with our immune systems and the
fact that we have to have immune systems
which are able to accommodate the
presence of an of an alien being and all
you know through pregnancy so it has to
be different women are more prone
therefore to having autoimmune diseases
um and
um much more yeah more prone to things
like
I don't know osteoporosis I mean a host
of things where you see massive massive
sex differences
um there's increasingly moves towards in
in Pharmaceuticals moves towards
creating drugs that are actually have
different formulations for medical women
because of the recognition that actually
our systems are so profoundly different
that it's not we can't just consider
women to be smaller men which is
normally what you do in dosing you have
to regard men and women as actually
having some really fundamental
differences which mean that our drug
interactions are different and yes this
is happening exactly the same time that
you have this like political discussion
around whether or not women even exist
as a category we're not not just sort of
gender goo
did you see the clip going around of uh
it was somebody suggesting that the
heart lead at six weeks was manufactured
by the patriarchy I I yeah I think I saw
a little bit of that American politician
was that right yeah that's where we're
at
this episode of the podcast was
sponsored by paleo Valley beef sticks if
you want to lose weight and be hotter
eat beef sticks instead of eating junk
it's an easy switch and they honestly
taste better than junk anyway and they
fill you up but they don't make you want
to keep eating who doesn't want beef
sticks Everyone likes beef sticks people
who say they don't like beef sticks are
lying paleo Valley is my go-to company
for my kid for beef sticks paleo valleys
beef sticks I've said beef sticks a lot
are made from 100 grass-fed and finished
beef not only are the cows grass-fed but
the spices they use to flavor their beef
sticks are also 100 organic and it's all
produced right here in the USA pedo
Valley also puts their beef sticks
through a natural fermentation process
which helps feed your microbiome so
these are the most gut friendly beef
sticks on the market and the snack you
can eat that'll fill you up won't make
you crash and is healthy head over to
paleoballey.com to check out their beef
sticks today that's
p-a-l-e-o-v-a-l-l-e-y.com for 100
grass-fed beef sticks enjoy the rest of
this episode yeah I mean that's whether
or not we want it to section asymmetry
is not going anywhere
and there has been such a reluctance
among most feminists to Grapple with it
particularly I think I'd say
particularly now but it's a
long-standing issue when it comes to the
psychological differences between men
and women the differences above the neck
we some feminists you know radical
feminists in particular can are
completely okay with the differences
below the neck
um and will recognize the importance of
things like strength differences
but the the fact that there are average
differences but very apparent ones at
the population level is is more
difficult if what you're aspiring to is
equality and as you as I said at the Top
If you if your interpretation of
equality is women being more like men
the fact that there are these
psychological differences that affect
our our behavior and our preferences is
quite difficult to reconcile so things
like women are more agreeable than men
are on average women are more neurotic
than men are on average and the fact
that our sexuality differences
differences are very obvious how the
population level yes there are
exceptions but in general men have more
unrestricted socio-sexuality they're
more interested in having casual sex in
watching porn in buying sex
men are much more likely to have
paraphilias or fetishes than women are
much more likely with with a few notable
and interesting exceptions so for
instance women are more likely to be
masochists and and so on but in all
other paraphernalia's men are
while being the lead
and I these are all things that have
become much more socially acceptable
post-sexual Revolution all preferences
and are much more likely to be found in
men than they are in women and something
like porn or prostitution or casual sex
not only are men more likely to be
interested in these things but they also
depend on women in order to enjoy them
right which therefore places demands of
women I think that what what we
basically have seen post-sexual
Revolution is if you can if you
understand two bell curves for men and
women along the sociosexuality scale you
know it's not a conspiracy it isn't to
do with um with some with some
exceptions this isn't generally to do
with men putting sort of interpersonal
pressure on women it's got It's got more
to do with culture and a new incentive
structure post pill but you what you're
basically seeing is women's the Bell
curved sort of trying to be dragged
upwards towards the the male ends and
and women be encouraged to behave more
like men in every possible way
um and I think in a lot of cases making
women miserable which is why I wrote the
book it's making a lot of men miserable
too I'd say the only the only group you
have really profited from this change in
sexual culture are
very high status men what about very
disagreeable intelligent women I'd say
in the workplace absolutely in terms of
sexuality I mean there are women who are
very high or very have on very
unrestricted sociosexuality I should say
properly are genuinely do enjoy casual
sex genuinely do want to watch porn
genuinely are interested in all kinds of
sexual adventure and experimentation
those women do absolutely exist but they
are rare and they will always suffer
from the risks associated with casual
sex like the risk of unwanted pregnancy
the fact that up
women being smaller and weaker means
that in any encounter between a man and
a woman on their own the woman is almost
always going to be much more physically
at risk of violence you know most women
can most most men can kill most women
with their bare hands and but not vice
versa so even a woman who
genuinely really loves casual sex
genuinely is really really driven to
have as many partners as possible aside
from any cultural pressure puts on her
she's always going to
run any run a risk
in any encounter and I think you have to
really want to have casual sex for that
risk to outweigh the benefit to you so
yes there are women who are exceptions
this are also men who are exceptions to
this and I think it's worth emphasizing
that male sexuality is quite quite is
quite flexible
um not in terms of sexual orientation
there's an interesting difference
between the Sexes that women are much
more bisexual more likely but bisexual
than men are
um you know 90 I don't know seven
percent of men are straight
um but they are flexible in terms of
their short-term versus long-term
strategy so there are circumstances in
which it's
it's
adaptive for men to want to have casual
sex and to you know in theory men can
conceive a child every time they help
they orgasm which obviously not true for
women because we have much greater
physical input into into reproduction
um so you can see why women would have
evolved to be much more cheesy about
their mates and much more careful about
having sex than our men
um and there is I describe in the book
as CAD mode there's you know CAD mode
for men
um is being driven towards having as
much being as promiscuous as you
possibly can get away with you know
but the other mode for men which I call
Dad mode
is orientated towards finding your wife
having children investing in those
children investing in that unit
stability you know like that there is
and there's a there's an element of
personal preference as some men are just
more likely to be
drawn towards one mode or the other
but there's also an incentive factor and
a cultural factor that if it's
advantageous in that moment for you to
do one or the other and if your culture
is telling you to do one or the other
then that's going to drag man you know
in one or other direction and I think
what we we see post-sexual revolution in
our sexual culture is
um the incentives are all towards pad
mode
yeah definitely definitely I think a lot
of that's how you're raised as well and
who your friends are and I think for me
growing up I went to an art school in
high school so I was in a I was in a
very liberal crowd I didn't even know
like what a conservative person was
until I think 2016 really like I didn't
know any conservatives
um and there was definitely a stigma
around getting married settling down
even dating somebody for a long period
of time it was pretty intense it was
very difficult to find somebody who's
interested in being married eventually
it did happen like I didn't know have
some friends that were like oh no I want
to find somebody and settle down and I
think that was because of how they were
raised is there was a big emphasis put
on that's the right way to live and for
families that had a more difficult time
or were somewhat broken then there was
less emphasis put on that and then those
are the people who still aren't married
and are still kind of screwing around at
like 32 which is also which you probably
get into not that risky for a man but
very difficult if they're dating a 32
year old woman who wants to have kids
completely completely and
yeah because I mean it's going back to
the limits of medical technology right
we we do have things like IVF
I'm sorry to say
um which
supposedly extends
the biological clock
but the failure rate of IVF is pretty
amazing
particularly when it comes to
age-related infertility for other causes
of infertility IVF is quite good but for
age-related infertility it's honestly
close to being a scam is that when you
harvest eggs late so I think that the
age of the eggs does matter
um quite a lot so if you harvest them
early and then do IVF later
but even then do you remember there was
that woman who appeared on the cover of
time
because she was she was one of the early
people to to invest in egg freezing and
she did it because she was in a very
high powered job I think in New York and
um
it was advantageous career-wise for her
to delay childbearing and so she was she
was this kind of glamorous shot on the
cover of Time Magazine and and her
promoting this this route to Liberation
for women
and then some years later she went to
halves she went to actually use the eggs
and discovered that almost all of them
had been destroyed in the process
hmm it's just devastating
um
it's it's a it it's it's by no means a
guarantee and I gotta say when you see
um
employers offering things like
everything to their young female
employees
this is increasingly a perk of jobs and
certain in some places particularly say
Silicon Valley
um or often often sorry into these
services or all these other things
um
they are doing it but if it's in their
interests yeah they are not doing that
they can't say that you know it
it's a very very risky route to go down
in terms of your chances of actually
having a live child at the end of the
process but it is this unfortunate fact
that a crucial moment in your
professional life
Maps aren't exactly to your your
fertility window
which is actually quite quite sure and
it has proved very difficult to to
expand it it's a funny thing that we can
we can keep people alive for a long time
and until recently life expectancy just
ticked up and up I mean it's now it's
now falling because of things like death
as despair but that's the great story of
the 20th and 21st centuries life
expectancy just goes up and up but
people our fertility window doesn't
and our and if anything all of our
social systems are completely massed
against it you know the healthiest time
really to be having children is in your
early 20s and yet that's exactly when
we've got everyone as an education you
don't own a home I know you don't you're
not you're not married in a relationship
like everything is completely
inappropriate for child rearing in a
social sense
in a biological sense it's perfect
timing but you know that's not that's
not the priority
um also things that we cut we struggle
to keep people healthy for a long time
so yes you stay alive for a long time
but from say the age of 70 you're going
to expect to have a lot of health
problems to be to be so much less
physically able than you once were
normally not really able to work
depending on what kind of work you do
certainly not able to do manual work
we've managed to extend old age but not
health is this the limits of medical
technology never never cease to amaze me
so I've had a difficult time I grew up
in a like my dad was traditional right
my mom stayed at home so I had a
stay-at-home mom and I was always
I I had this kind of
a difficult time understanding what I
was supposed to do because
on one hand I was told getting a PhD was
massively important going to University
was massively important but also you
should be a stay-at-home mom
and I can remember as a teenager like
adding up the years and being like okay
if it's easiest to have kids in your 20s
but I'm also supposed to get a PhD it
wasn't even Bachelor degrees like that's
for sure but like PhD is what you really
want it's like how do I do both and I
can remember just being like I don't
know if I can like I don't know if I can
do both unless like I don't know how I
can do both and then I had some health
problems which delayed schooling and was
like okay well now the years are
completely off I'm not going to get a
PhD until I'm like 31 and then
like how do you balance everything in
there
um and I think I had a difficult time
understanding what the average female is
like because
I'm extremely disagreeable and for my
entire life I thought everybody else was
just like me like it was until I was 24.
I had I have no idea why this was
because my dad being who he is I knew
people had personality differences but I
couldn't wrap my head around what those
actually manifested like so when I had
conversations uh I couldn't understand
why people acted differently in
conversations than I did until I was
like 24. I don't know if other people
have that problem but it took me a long
time and it was difficult for me to
figure out
what I should feel like and so
the conversation's interesting because I
don't think I think like the average
female because my disagreeableness is so
high what do you think the average
female looks like what do you think they
want
I'm single people so yeah super which I
do think actually is a real factor in
all the sexual culture stuff it's a
question I get sometimes is why are
women putting up with this
why would women put up with a culture
that is not geared towards their
preferences
I just anecdotally and also in in media
culture whatever you see so many
examples of women who will
um
go along with situationships so-called
right or have
um casual sexual relationships without
any kind of commitment without even
displays of affection
um which they desperately crave and will
do qualified sex acts that they don't
enjoy that they don't really want to do
but they're trying to please this man
whatever and the question is why would
women put up with this when when in
general women are the more
are generally the the sex with more
choices when it comes to mates because
we know from all the dating data which
has proved to be so useful for sex
researchers that
um the hypergamy Instinct in women the
the
subconscious desire to to marry up and
to
um be drawn towards higher status men
than oneself which men don't have men
are quite happy to generally have
relationships with women of the same or
lower status than themselves but women
are not means that you end up with women
kind of clustering towards the higher
status man I think the figures on Tinder
is it's like 10 of men get 60 of likes
the top 10 Cinema that is and then the
bottom 90 are getting very little
whereas women are generally get a lot of
likes but they're getting likes from
them that they're not interested in and
I think that what's going on is because
you've lifted
the monogamy restriction
not legally you know polygamy is still
illegal at least in the UK
um that is probably the next Frontier
yeah polyamorous are going to start
clamoring to have their their
relationships recognized in law but for
now it's still illegal but in practice
because pre-marital and extramarital
Sexes now
socially acceptable
um
these high status men who in previous
era would have got married and would
have removed themselves from a dating
pool instead are able to have the
serially monogamous or even able to have
simultaneous relationships with with
women who don't mind or even realize you
know that they're part of these horims
right digital homes and
um I think that's why those women end up
those those High status men are able to
really really set the terms
because if they if a woman doesn't say
have sex on a first date
it's easy enough to find another woman
who will
so you end up with a slightly artificial
level of competition between women who
you know there are actually enough men
to go around but there aren't enough men
that they actually want to be with to go
around and so they're competing for a
minority of men who basically have I
mean it's kind of Open Season they can
demand that their own preferences be met
so what's the what's the solution here
now that we're in this predicament
I mean on an individual level it is
quite possible for people to just choose
to be a bit more Trad the the challenge
is of course finding a partner who wants
who wants that too but I I'm noticing
around me are quite a significant turn
against this stuff it's increasingly
common in Elite circles as well you know
there's this this apparent turn towards
Catholicism among young New Yorkers and
I see it among young londoners as well a
greater conservatism among a sort of
subsection of the elite you can choose
to to do that you know you can still get
married you can still not have
premarital sex you can still choose to
be a stay-at-home mum have loads of
children I mean it's more difficult
because things like being a stay-at-home
mum and in an economic environment that
that's really challenging
is just harder than it used to be
um you won't have the social support
that you used to have if that's the
route that you're choosing
um
you will forego status
to some extent
but
it's still possible so I do have advice
for for readers along along those lines
you know you you I think that one change
could come about quite easily is just
I think part of the I said sorry I was
saying before but part of the reason why
you see women putting up with nonsense
is because of the hypergamy effect but I
think the other reason is to do an
agreeableness and agreeable people just
find it really difficult to to be
assertive in those situations and when
when for instance the norm becomes
having sex on a first date
and indeed the norm becomes having sex
before marriage per se you know it used
to be that if the social expectation was
that you you wouldn't have sex before
marriage then there's no conversation it
is just assumed after a date that you
know we will not be having sex that's
the default Now the default is to have
sex and that means that women are put in
the situation sometimes very agreeable
women who are really Keen to please
these you know these these desirable men
whatever where they have to be defending
their own sexual boundaries even if
they're actually quite reluctant and off
it's often off from what you see in me
too cases
where women are describing situations
where they're that you know they're with
a man who potentially they are actually
quite romantically interested in after a
date whatever Aziz Ansari was the famous
example do you remember that one
the the actor Aziz Ansari who had a date
with a woman
um went back to his place and she didn't
want to have sex he did he didn't rape
her there wasn't anything illegal that
happened she never really said no but
she also wasn't was was a bit reluctant
and and made it she felt made it evident
non-verbally that she was reluctant he
apparently didn't think so
um and they ended up and they ended up
having sex and she felt really violated
and felt really distressed and she later
she later wrote about this and it became
a whole thing she had to express what
what happened in the terms of consent
and so the the conversation that
happened afterwards was was this really
consensual what you know what was this
sexual assault Etc I think the answer to
that is no it wasn't sexual assault and
on a legal level but it also wasn't good
yeah and he didn't behave well and he
didn't behave
like a gentleman right is what you would
have said historically he didn't behave
like a gentleman he didn't demonstrate
chivalry he put pressure on a woman who
what who who he ought to have recognized
was reluctant but the thing is that when
when the expectation particularly when
you're talking about a fan going on a
date with a celebrity which is the
circumstances there and you've gone back
to his house the expectation was that
they would have sex and so it was
incumbent on her to be assertive
and to say no and agreeable people find
that really hard so I think that's
that's very often what's going on and I
think that if there's one change that
could happen quite swiftly potentially
is if we had a bit of a change in
and norms and expectations
and if women felt more confident in
demanding certain things that I hear so
often from young women in particular
this you know I'm afraid of being frigid
I'm afraid of being approved I'm afraid
of of being considered low status
because I don't want to do XYZ if if the
status split
and um different expectations were in
place
then I think you would see women and
Little Men Behaving quite differently
because women women are The Gatekeepers
you know most of the time what you see
now for instance at the moment is you
see there's this Dreadful phenomenon on
Tick Tock of young women showing off
their bruises that they've got some
having rough sex with their boyfriends
like really young women teenagers so
they've got bruises on their neck and
they'll like take tick tocks off them
and this is this is considered to be
really desirable I think all women will
show off about how many partners they've
had I think that that's coming from a
misunderstanding of male sexuality
I think that we because we're we're all
kind of collectively in denial about how
profoundly different men and women are
on the selling level as we were saying
but also psychologically and I think
that a lot of young women don't realize
that men are much more geared towards
having emotional sex than they are yeah
and actually are much more willing to
have sex with women they really they
wouldn't care if they got hit by a bus
next week frankly
and so things like having you know being
able to to entice a man into bed or or
to have rough sex or whatever it's not
actually much of an achievement it's
pretty easy to do that particularly as a
as a young woman but because of that
misunderstanding of the fact that men
regard sex quite differently from women
I think that these these young women
don't know that because they've not
learned it yet and because the culture
completely misinforms them about reality
um I think that if they did know that
I don't think they'd be putting these
videos on tick tock
yeah so that's a kind of modest aim to
let me know it's a good aim um I agree I
think that that's kind of similar to my
misunderstanding of Personality
differences until I was 24 just not I
just didn't I knew but I didn't
understand what that looked like I think
that probably goes for differences
between men and women too I still have a
hard time with that like even with my
husband and I am fully educated in the
differences between men and women and I
still have a hard time
understanding why responses to
situations can differ between us
and it's because we're you know I I mean
I have that issue with looking at other
women as well but I think it's very hard
for people to to understand how
different men and women can be or people
can be from each other
It's Tricky I I found that having a baby
actually I mean I I like you I knew I
knew these things academically I found
that having a baby made them really
really apparent
um the sense to the sensing which we are
sort of slaves to our biology and
actually we don't we don't have nearly
as much control over our our instincts
and our behaviors as we think because
the way in which maternal and paternal
Instinct stiffer for instance is really
striking and particularly during so my
son's 16 months old now you know that
instinct to check that your baby's
breathing yeah which everyone does I
didn't know initially that that was a
natural thing to do and so you you feel
a bit crazy constantly going in and
checking checking the baby's breathing
but then I and I still do it
occasionally but when the new bondage at
all times I found out recently that
apparently chimpanzee mothers do that
oh that's cool yeah I didn't know that
that's cool yeah
um and my husband doesn't do that or a
little bit maybe but it's not the same
kind of desperate drive towards like
I've got to check the baby's breathing
which all of my all of my mum friends
have said they have as well
um
yeah yeah they are the thing that I
noticed so uh the thing that I noticed
when I had I have a five-year-old
daughter this was very strange and I
thought this was on a serious biological
level is as soon as she was born I
couldn't sleep I don't know I don't know
what your experience was but I used to
be able to sleep through anything
Wherever Whenever and then as soon as
she was born it was like she just
breathed funny right like it's not
crying she'd be like huh just like this
tiny little and I'd be like it'd be like
an electric zap through my body and I'd
be awake I was like yeah that's crazy
and she's five now and it hasn't gone
away so I sleep with like a mask and
white noise and if my husband moves then
I'm kind of awake and that wasn't the
case before and it happened as soon as
she was born did that happen to you with
noises yeah yeah oh my gosh that's
exhausting it really is
um and I found as well that I um
so initially we didn't go sleep because
I was so scared of all the Sid stuff and
that ended up kind of gradually letting
him stay in the bed and one of the and
because I and I did that partly because
I read about like the anthropology of
infant sleep and the fact that infant
sleeping in the same bed as their
mothers crucially not their fathers so
it's not safe to have fathers sleep with
you yeah it is safe to have mothers sit
with the infant as long as there are
certain like risk factors aren't present
like premature prematurity or and mother
has to not be on sleeping drugs or drunk
or anything like that but that in most
circumstances it is safe for mothers to
sleep with a baby
um because you are so attuned to them
all the time you're not going to roll
over your baby and actually what you end
up doing instinctively is forming a c
shape around yeah
completely and that is apparently the
natural thing the c-shape it's what they
they write about in um studies like
were all like on your arm you know and
yeah oh that's so cool okay I did that
yeah
um wow and uh yeah that's just that's
because because your body is like
completely set on this I found as well
when I in the early in the early weeks
in particular I'd like I would I would
only ever dream about my son I didn't
dream about anything else and I would if
I closed my eyes I could see his face
like I had that level of constant
Attunement towards the baby which then
gradually lapses yeah yeah and that that
link becomes a little bit less you know
but you know they talk about the fourth
trimester yeah we give birth to our
babies too early really and so you you
have to have this intense dependency
initially
um yeah which has all sorts of social
effects obviously as well because it
just
is a very uncomfortable if if
you're a liberal individualist and
you're all about people having autonomy
then motherhood is a huge problem
because mothers can't be autonomous
and there's this really you know you're
not really talking about two individuals
when you talk about a mother and a baby
because the baby definitely can't be
considered in that way because because
he or she is just completely dependent
on on other people for Staying Alive
but mothers also are so emotionally
drawn towards them but even if you've
got formula even if you've got daycare
even if you've got all these things
which can kind of
um physically
lessen their dependency that emotional
link is insane
and you know try as you might trying to
persuade each mothers to to break it if
that's your social project you're going
to fail
that's also cruel it would have been so
much easier like I had Scarlett yeah
she's five so I had her five years ago
and it really decimated my social life
like and I was prepared for that but it
would have been so much like there's a
reason women most women aren't doing
that right especially if you're in a
more liberal Circle because you have a
kid and you're 25 or like 24 or 23. even
26. yeah it's like okay I was 29 and I
felt really young yeah I know 29 even
yeah right like and then you're the only
person especially if you're like
probably if you're educated or if you're
more liberal you're the only person in
your friend group that has a kid I had
responses from friends that are like oh
you're ruining your life and like that
was and then the neighborhood I moved
into at the time too
I was looked down on like I had a kid
and they're like well what's your job it
was these older women too these like 56
year old women were just like oh you're
just staying at home
okay yeah and I was like wow so now my
entire Social Circle is broken my
neighborhood everyone in my neighborhood
is 15 years older than me with the kids
that are the same age it was just like I
have the same good luck with that and
it's worth it for sure it's worth it and
I think
um trying to like I appreciate what
you're doing because what needs to
happen I think is it needs to be made
cool again because women need it right
it needs to be cool it needs to be cool
to be a gentleman it used to be cool to
be a dad like having it's so attractive
to have a man say
hey I want you to have babies with me
and I want to take care of you like that
is so attractive I don't know when that
stopped being attractive I think it
still is it is but it like just
yeah this is persuading people I know I
know uh completely and it it also ends
up with a slightly unfortunate like I
found around here because we live in we
live in London and we're in one of these
parts of London where yeah like
at my hospital the average age for first
baby was like late 30s the average age
that's crazy yeah wow and and that was
including you know where I where I gave
birth
covered an area with quite a high South
Asian immigrant population where women
were having babies a lot younger so it
was it was that balanced with the with
the upper middle class women who were
having them really late and um and also
most most women go back to work quite
quickly so you can find quite soon that
if you
um if you want to be stay at home or if
like me at the time I was I was at home
part of the week
um you have no one to hang out with
so they're all at work obviously and
their social schedule isn't going to fit
in with you you know you want to be
having like mid-morning
um socializing you can't be doing late
nights and stuff it's yeah it's
difficult breaking yourself yeah you
have to see you have to seek out people
who are also making your eccentric
decisions
yeah yeah and hopefully that'll become
more and more common it was so
interesting I spent a period of time in
Serbia
and if you went out to like because the
streets are there people would hang out
at like little coffee shops
there were people my age that would have
two or three kids with their friends
like that would also have two or three
kids and the like men are drinking beer
women are drinking coffee or having a
beer kids are like running around them
and they were 28 year olds and they had
kids from like a kid on their lap and
then two kids that were under five
and I can remember looking at that being
like they're having a good time that
looks like fun they haven't lost their
lives they still have friends they're
out socializing but their kids are there
I was like that just doesn't exist here
and then when I was in in Russia they
have restaurants set up so that you'll
have a really nice like steakhouse
restaurant and at one area the
restaurant they'll hire it's generally
like a kind of a grandmother type person
that'll you can give your kid to for
dinner yeah and they'll entertain your
kid and it's just part of the restaurant
or they'll have little rooms that are
full of toys so parents can go and you
can say hey you you know here's a kid
for a few hours the kids have a blast
parents get a break but Society is set
up so that people can do that and that
Institute like those types of
Institutions don't exist at all here
for Less are super deliberate so I'm
going on a weekend soon which is put on
by a by a conservative think tank and
because they're very deliberately
pro-family they are providing
deliberately providing each other
everything is family orientated you know
but that's not normal so I initially
thought I can't possibly go because I
don't you know and I spoke to him and
they said no no this is genuinely
profoundly they've made it yeah yeah but
you have to kind of you have to go that
extra mile it was also something to be
fair that a lot of um
feminist did like doing conferences in
the second way of times doing
conferences and providing crashes
because you know if if children then
mothers can't participate because they
they come as a package
um I think also this thing of um the
fact that we don't really see kids
running around in restaurants and stuff
I think it's also because that feeling
of social disapproval I think we've
never had a time probably in human
history where so many adults have have
no experience of children
because you can now make it a really
long time and never have held a baby
because you're you're not likely to have
a lot of siblings who are having kids
and not like kids all of your friends
are also delaying childbearing you're
not really seeing kids out about
you can you can reach the age of 40 or
something and you've basically never
been in charge of a child I mean I used
to work as a nanny yeah so I'm unusual
in that sense
um but
I it's kind of no wonder that you have
people sort of whinging about children
on airplanes and women around children
in restaurants all this stuff like
children of members of society too I
mean there's one thing to obviously
complain about parents not being
sufficiently attentive but just yeah
definitely children you know like they
they
they behave differently from Grown arms
and you you kind of have to learn you
just have to learn that from being
around them and I think that as a
society we're increasingly not familiar
with what children are like
which then makes it more difficult to as
a parent to be bringing children into
places like restaurants or or churches
think think how noisy churches must have
been
I feel like I can error I can almost
remember
um and I'm 30. I feel like when I was a
kid the weddings I went to and I went to
church I didn't go to church often I
went to church a few times but I
remember every time I went to one of
those events a baby would cry and then
someone would get up and go outside with
a baby that was just the norm at those
events and now it's not
including a child-free weddings if you
come across thesis
to a child-free wedding but this is
apparently
a thing definitely legit I think it's
the norm I think that's crazy to do with
it is crazy I think it it has to do with
how much people are spending on weddings
as well
yeah yeah
yeah which I think as well you know is a
consequence of um there's a consequence
of the bill because because
well consequence well a consequence of
the death of the marriage institution
which is Downstream with the pill
because I think that now it is so easy
to get divorced
there's so much less permanence in
general attached to marriage but I think
people don't feel as if it has much
inherent meaning anymore whereas you
know back in the day where you really
couldn't get divorced if you just show
up to if you go to Gretna Green and just
you two and a witness you've completely
transformed your life
even if the day was pretty trivial and
all of the senses and you didn't spend
any money on it you've completely
transformed your life whereas now you
haven't actually and everyone kind of
knows that so I think people try and
invest meaning by spending money
and making it into a massive event and
having these kind of big Society
weddings which were not normal
um for say our grandparents generation
they wouldn't people didn't spend that
that kind of big reception dinner and
everything that was what people did in
the upper classes that wasn't normal
um whereas now it's expected and it ends
up of course being another impediment to
getting married because you if you kind
of yeah have a big wedding then you
might delay it yeah and not invite
children which are actually the whole
point of marriage right that's the
original that's the original purpose of
marriage is to
provide a basis on which to
our children
whereas now the connection is not at all
obvious it's seen as a sort of means of
self-fulfillment maybe
an accomplishment in that you found your
Forever person it's not seen as a
a precondition of family formation
hopefully things get better I think I
think I've seen I think things are going
to get better I it felt like things were
going to get worse in 2018 and I feel
like things are getting better now I
think the popularity in some of these
more traditional ideas and the
acceptance of them there's
things have split more but I I feel like
there are more people talking about hey
having a family is okay wanting to be a
stay-at-home mom is okay kids are kids
are great like I think it's more popular
I hope and I think men are getting more
interested in the idea as well
I think or I could just be in a bubble I
think you're right I think there's
something happening someone said to me
um the other day that uh if you if you
re if you had written this book 10 years
ago it would have been a flop but but
this seems to be for some reason a
moment where
I haven't had very much negative
response actually not at all oh that's
cool um
overwhelmingly positive and so much
bigger than I thought as well I get like
I get emails several times a day from
people who are saying
wow this book has had such an impact on
me and I I sort of feel like I'm just
saying obvious stuff but I think that
we're living in a time where the obvious
stuff needs to be said agreed okay so
where can people go to find your book
and where can people go online to find
you
so um best place to find me is on
Twitter so I'm at Louise underscore M
underscore Perry
and the book is called the case against
the sexual Revolution a new Guide to Sex
in the 21st century and it came out uh
like two weeks ago in the states and is
available
all over the world and is about to be
translated into a bunch of other
languages but for now it's just in
English that is so cool congratulations
thank you so much
[Music]